okay
well thank you very much thank you Brett
for that very nice and generous
introduction you know I figure over the
past 10 years I have introduced and
listened to probably about a hundred
views from the top but I've been very
impressed that almost every speaker
that's been here has viewed this forum
as such a great privilege and I think
that's because of who you are and what
you represent you know you are among the
most capable members of your generation
you're the best that our society has to
offer and you represent our hopes for
the future of world leadership and the
impact that can have on how our
organizations perform and how they serve
society so a chance to offer my views on
leadership on a view from the top is
just a rare opportunity and a great
privilege I thought as a view from the
top it seemed logical to address these
two questions what's the top and what's
the view like
here's my definition of the top look
it's any position where you take
responsibility for a group with a
mission to fulfill it's any job any role
any position you take responsibility you
feel it and you own it and it's a group
that has an important mission to fulfill
and when you take that definition and
you look at modern organizations and our
society today you realize there's many
many places within an organization that
you in fact can take responsibility for
a group most of us start our working
lives working for ourselves and are
responsible for our own work but pretty
soon you already have or I know you will
will be responsible for a group of
people a team of people have their work
and that group may change over time to
become a group of other managers who in
turn have their own teams or your group
may be a group of a business function or
corporate function like HR or strategy
or finance it may be a business where
you've got a group of customers and
employees and you've got products and a
geography to cover in bigger
organizations it might even be a group
of businesses it might even be an entire
enterprise there are lots of tops that
are possible I left the GSB a little
over 40 years ago and I work for 4 big
institutions and during that time I was
fortunate to have 10 chances at a top
and they ranged as indicated in that
earlier chart from small groups to large
groups from line to staff from
businesses to corporate or business
functions sometimes groups of businesses
and in a couple of occasions the entire
enterprise I've never quite sure where
to put the business school because in
addition to having faculty and staff of
about 500 we have 900 students seeking
degrees we have 2,500 students coming
for executive education that are a
little different from staff and
different from customer
and we have seven schools at the
University so I put it kind of as a
business but all of these tops have the
same thing in common you're responsible
for a group of people with a mission to
fulfill and you're trying to change that
group for the better now what I should
say at the outset is that just because
your job sits at the top of an
organization chart there's a reality to
how groups work that is often a surprise
to people for example 10 years ago when
the GSB Dean search committee almost 10
years to this month invited me to be the
Dean and I accepted that invitation they
presented me with a t-shirt that had the
following diagram across the front
now while this is not exactly how the
GSB works I knew at the time and I know
even more today as I've thought about
and studied and tried to teach about
leadership that really in virtually all
of these tops in all leadership roles
there's there's an informal dependence
on other people that is in many ways
much more important and more powerful
than the power or the authority that is
implied by an organization chart that
puts your job at the top because here's
the reason it's all about responsibility
when you're at the top it's not about
power or fame or fortune it's about
responsibility you're responsible for
the group you're responsible for moving
that group in the right direction
over time so that it gets better and
you're the only one that has that total
responsibility across all dimensions all
parts of the group how the group acts
how it thinks how it feels how it
performs
that's something you can't do alone and
that's something you really can't do
with power I always like what Margaret
Thatcher had to say about power she said
you know being powerful is like being a
lady if you have to say you are you
aren't
I thought that would sink in but that's
what the top is all about it's about
responsibility it's about 24/7
responsibility for the group with what
abrams ales nick called an imp Elling
need to do better so what about the view
what's it like well let me say four
things about the view first of all since
you're at the top and you're responsible
for the Butte for the group
you better have a view you better
develop a view that is to say where is
the group now and where would you like
to see the group headed in what
direction and at what speed groups need
direction they need some kind of vision
for what better looks like if you're
trying to change for the better which
you are
I always thought Michael Dell had a
great way of expressing it he said you
have to show that you know the way even
if you have no idea what to do and it's
true you have to know a general sense of
direction about where the group ought to
go it's not something you have to do
alone it has to get developed it's not
something you have to do in your first
hundred days but you have to see that
the group does have a sense of direction
and that it's there and it's one of the
two things when you're at a top that you
just can't delegate this is one of those
things you have to make sure happens a
group needs a strategy and these a
framework that guides the choices that
determine its nature and direction and
as the person responsible at the top
you're in the best position to have the
best view of where it ought to go when I
went to Australia in 1993 as Brett
mentioned I saw a very troubled
institution had suffered the biggest
loss in Australian corporate history and
they had tried to be Australia's world
bank but it's a big world out there lots
of risks resources aren't there to
really do that I could see
that if it really focused on being
Australia's best bank the best bank in
Australia for Australians the best bank
in New Zealand for New Zealanders that
was its home turf where it had been for
nearly 200 years that it could be a
really successful institution and I also
could see because I had spent 22 years
at Wells Fargo trying to be the best
bank in California that it was possible
I knew how products and systems and and
and groups could come together but I
didn't actually know how to do it in
this different country in this different
culture with different laws and people
but I had a general sense of direction
when I came to the Stanford Business
School in 1999 I knew it was a great
school
but I also knew it could be better I
thought particularly we could be better
along the dimensions of preparing people
for global management and for leadership
but I didn't really know how or how we
might do that so you have to have a view
of view and you have to then help others
see what it is that you see when you
take that view because there's no sense
having a vision or a view if you can't
make it happen you've got to turn turn
that vision into reality and there are a
couple of ways that you can help
yourself do that you can push the group
along through the implementation of
really useful really valuable and
important management systems planning
organizing staffing directing
controlling these are all things I've
found extraordinarily valuable whether
in a banker at a school they help you
push the group in the right direction
they bring a discipline and a focus to
the organization that's extremely
valuable and they have a lot to do with
how the group acts but they have very
little do to do with how it thinks or
how it feels to do that you've got to
pull the group along and that takes
communication a lot of communication
John Gardner had a wonderful phrase
leaders find the words
and you have to find words that connect
with people you have to help others see
what it is that you see and you try
different things until something clicks
or connects or works it's no good
talking to people about being the best
bank in Australia if nobody knows what
that means it's better to find a way to
explain it in terms of developing or
delivering better solutions for
customers day in and day out so they
begin to see how their job fits with
their role in the firm it's no good
talking about being a great school if
it's to Jenner to general and not giving
people some sense of direction it's
better to talk about the three C's of a
new curriculum new collaboration or a
new campus you have to enlist followers
when you're in a role at the top and
you're very dependent on those followers
what you want are people who are
inspired who are committed who are
motivated and it's your job to instill
confidence in them that's very hard to
do change is hard and most people resist
change and yet the group needs change to
get better they need to know what's in
it for them to make that change and
earning followers is earning their trust
you earn their trust by being
trustworthy Jack Welch always says look
at the top it's not about you it's about
them which is so true and in particular
it's about the relationship between you
and them and in developing that
relationship I'd say the third thing
about the view is you have to figure out
how it's going there are management
systems that are really helpful but when
you're at the top people don't always
tell you what you need to hear indeed
that's probably the single biggest blind
spot or difficulty when you're in a role
like that and here's where the power of
questions from the top is probably even
more important than the view from the
top Ron Heifetz who's a leadership
scholar at the Kennedy School has a
wonderful phrase that one can lead with
no more than a question in hand
sometimes it's as simple a question is
why do we do it that way or I can recall
going into a very very large group of
managers in my early days at Westpac it
was entirely filled with middle-aged men
and I said where are all the women it
wasn't really a question that needed an
answer it was a question that set in
motion a whole change in behavior not
just in our company but throughout
corporate Australia so the power of a
question is pretty extraordinary you
have to invite open criticism and you
have to be willing to invite open
criticism there are all kinds of ways to
do this and I've tried them all managing
by walking around town halls where you
encourage people to speak up
confidential surveys of staff or
employees or customers hotlines one of
the things we did at Westpac in the
early days was the first Friday of every
month any employee in the company could
pick up the phone between nine and ten
and call the CEO and I found that if two
or three people referred to a similar
problem you could pretty much be sure it
was a problem that's all it took out of
40,000 people if there were two or three
courageous souls who called and they
were triangulating on the same issue the
chances were pretty good that there was
a real problem there that was so
valuable to know about and head off that
you never knew from the management
systems got to invite the open criticism
and you've got to listen and listen
really well
when you're at the top you need to
understand the world of customers and
staff what's it like to be a customer in
your organization what's it like to be a
staff member how are they thinking and
how are they feeling and people need to
know that you understand their world if
they're going to trust you you need
their trust to make the changes
are so important for the good of the
group because if the group doesn't
change it falls behind and the last
thing I'd say about the view is you have
to be the view and this is perhaps the
most surprising thing to people this is
the second thing you can't delegate
because you're at the top you are the
group's representative you're the symbol
of the group you stand for the group
everywhere you go and everything you do
leaders cast long shadows you hear the
phrase the tone at the top and indeed
the tone at the top is more important
perhaps than the view from the top you
need to earn the trust and respect of
people so they'll follow and want to
make the changes people will trust and
follow not a perfect leader they don't
want a perfect leader a genuine leader
somebody they can trust somebody who
demonstrates that they care more about
the group and the group's welfare that
about the welfare of the leader this was
really brought home to me by a very sad
incident in Australia when one of our
staff members in New Zealand a member of
our branch in a little branch outside of
Wellington was shot and killed during a
bank holdup so first time in my entire
career I'd ever been involved with a
fatality in a place I worked and we were
all extremely distraught and concerned
and my HR director came in and said well
you're going to the funeral aren't you
and I said oh I don't think so I think
I'd be kind of awkward there I mean I
don't know the people this is a very sad
situation for their family I'm intruding
on their privacy
oh no he said you have to go it made me
a little uncomfortable but the more he
pushed the more I listened and the more
I decided maybe he's right and I better
go and I learned for myself just how
important
and the symbol of the organization
communicates to the family who are so
grateful and pleased to 7,000 staff in
New Zealand who were so grateful and
pleased in a way I couldn't possibly
have imagined I only really came to see
it years later when after 9/11 I was
reading Rudy Giuliani's book on
leadership and I came to chapter 11 and
the title of chapter 11 is weddings
discretionary funerals mandatory and in
that chapter
Giuliani talks about when things are
going great the leader doesn't have to
show up it's when people are hurting and
things are not so good that they need
leadership in other words you have to
find ways to use all of yourself your
words your deeds your emotions your
energy to build that relationship it's
it's not about you it's about them it's
about a relationship between you and
them and in building that relationship
you've got to use all of yourself John
Gardner used to remind me that
leadership is not a science it's an art
and it's a performing art and in this
performing art he said you are the
instrument and you need to know how to
play that instrument and play it well
you have to be the change that you want
to see in the organization just as
Gandhi told us be the change you want to
see in the world when you're at the top
and in that role and you want to see the
organization operate in a certain way
you have to be the change that you want
to see and others the role model that
people copy people want to have a sense
of hope they need that they need a sense
of optimism and they need to see it in
you when you're at the top
well that's my view from the top and
what it's like but what about you and
yours to come because there's not a
doubt in my mind that you will be at
tops in your life you will be involved
in group effort and at some point you'll
take responsibility for that group
effort
I hope wherever you start in an
organization that you start right away
thinking about the top thinking about
how should this group change for the
better
what does group success look like I hope
you'll accept responsibility for how
well the group performs whether it's in
your job description or not and when it
really becomes part of your job
description that you'll then acquire the
expertise that can only come from
experience the experience of actually
assuming that top or that leadership
responsibility you know the Chinese have
a wonderful saying that I hear and I
forget I see
and I remember but I do and I understand
the deepest form of learning is
understanding it's why in our leadership
fellows we actually have people do we
have them take responsibility for others
we have them coach we have them give
feedback so they know what it feels like
so they understand leadership in a way
you can't possibly learn from a lecture
or from reading a book and then when
you're at the top I hope that you will
be yourself be yourself because you've
got to be a genuine person of integrity
to be effective but you can be yourself
with more skill that's the great thing
about life you can continually learn by
listening and practice and learning from
mistakes and trying new behaviors this
is all made even more powerful if you're
doing what matters most to you if you're
doing work
that you think ought to be done and it
ought to be done by you and for each of
you that's a separate calling and a
separate voice the key thing is that you
care about a group achieving a better
future for itself there's nothing more
satisfying than being a part of such an
effort where you care about a group
achieving a better future and it indeed
achieves a better future I can tell you
that and I hope you have an opportunity
to experience that
after all if not you who else and if not
now or soon after you leave this place
when one of the great joys of being Dean
is that I get to see over and over again
in hundreds of ways the impact that this
place has on the lives of people who go
through this experience for example in
September when we broke ground over here
on our new campus phil knight talked at
dinner and he said you know without the
GSB there'd be no Nike pretty powerful
amazing and a couple of months ago I was
in London at a big Stanford alumni event
chatting with one of our younger alums
from Germany and as I usually do to make
conversation I said well how's business
expecting it's not so good you know the
economy is in recession things are tough
in the Europe and he said things are
really going well and he told me about
how he and a couple partners had bought
a few companies small and medium sized
companies that had turned them around
revitalized them were really creating
value and productivity was appearing and
he was so excited and he stopped in
mid-sentence looked at me and said you
know without the Stanford GSB I never
would have had a confidence to do this I
thought that's pretty great you know we
don't have a course in confidence here
we teach strategy marketing HR
operations accounting and finance and
but there's a confidence that comes when
you acquire a way of thinking and
approaching situations and have tested
it with other extremely bright people
that lets you know that things are
possible and that you can indeed play
that kind of role after all it's your
life that's the one changed by coming
here that's what we're talking about in
this slogan you're a different person
when you leave here then when you
entered I've seen it now over and over
again ten years in succession and your
work will involve working in groups and
those groups will be trying to fulfill
missions and those are missions if done
well can change the world Margaret Mead
reminds us never doubt that a small
group of thoughtful committed citizens
can change the world indeed it's the
only thing that ever has now I can give
you my view from the top you hear me you
might forget you see me you might
remember but remember I do and I
understand you will only really
understand if you do it if you get
involved in the doing not talking
analyzing thinking about consulting
about investing but doing
take on a leadership role be responsible
for a group helping that group to change
for the better to fulfill an important
mission that's where that confidence
comes from that those guys we're talking
about that's how you learn leadership
the only real learning for leadership is
leadership taking on a leadership role
it's all about the doing so in the words
of our great friend and alum Phil Knight
please do it please do it and I hope
you'll do it with the intensity and the
focus and putting all of yourself into
it that I think you see in this young
pitcher I can tell you because I know
him well and I watch him often that he's
not just putting his mind and body into
this he's putting his heart and soul
into this this is work that ought to be
done and he believes he ought to do it
and it's what matters most to him at
that moment in time I enjoy watching him
but I look forward just as much to
watching you as you assume your tops and
you develop your views and you come back
and share them with us thank you very
much for the honor of presenting my view
from the top
so I'd be happy if you have any
questions in the time we have about 15
minutes I'd be delighted to take any
questions inside stuff about the GSB
well my plans are to figure out what I'm
going to do for the next year for as I
said in the last 40 years I've had a job
where I was responsible for a group 24
hours a day seven days a week and I'm
looking forward to doing a variety of
things where others are responsible and
I'm more the coach the consultant the
advisor I'm involved with several boards
I'm going to teach my seminar in the
fall that I've been teaching in the
second year seminar series and I love
doing that and I'll I'll see I'm going
to take a little bit of time off and
then a lot of things I'm looking at no
one full-time thing a number of
part-time things and particularly around
around leadership yeah so I'm just
wondering over the years you've had lots
of different leadership positions is
there a theme to what most kept you up
at night as a leader well sure I think
the theme is is the people I mean it's
about a group of people and are we doing
well are we doing right by them are we
are we moving in the right direction do
we have the right people in the right
places and what if we don't and I'm
responsible for for that difficult
choice of making some changes and I
think the most difficult things are the
ones that are so emotional where you
have to gather and develop that
emotional strength to make a change to
make a call as you see it because you
think it's the right thing for the group
even though it may involve short-term
pain for some people thank that's the
one thing
what's my plan for the school yeah I
have a plan for the school going forward
which is a new dean it's called a
lateral
but of course I have hopes I'm like I'm
an alum you know I love the school I
want it to be a great school I want to
see it get better and better which means
it'll change and it'll change in ways
that I don't quite anticipate just as I
tried to change what the people before
me had been doing in in ways and it
wasn't something you can do on your own
you have to enlist faculty and staff and
alumni who really want to help make that
change happen I think we're on a great
trajectory I think we've got a lot to do
to kind of continually refine and
rethink our curriculum and is it
preparing our students for leadership in
the 21st century in the best way
possible there's so many possible and
exciting things we can be doing with the
University and of course very excited to
see how the new campus will really it'll
really change our culture I think it'll
change the place in exciting ways
because it's going to be the most
exciting place to be at Stanford
University it's where people want to
come and gather and I think there's
unlimited opportunities for events and
collaborations there that'll put the
Business School on the map but I'm very
excited about just continually
challenging ourselves with how do we
better prepare people particularly how
do we prepare you to act and I think we
prepare you really well how to think
we're really good at the thinking part
you know the analysis the alternatives
the decision rules but ultimately you're
out there you got to act you've got to
have the moral courage to act on a
situation and there's only so much we
can do but we have to stretch ourselves
and say how could we do that better
because that's where we can help you I
think even more
you pay some pretty formal formable
tasks as a leader I just wonder if
you've ever doubted yourself in Heidi
over confident trepidation definitely
you always doubt yourself somebody I was
on the plane with my wife headed for
Sydney wondering what in the world am i
doing
going to a place I don't know a
situation I don't know with no support
network no friends no anything 40,000
people lots of trouble and a lot of fear
somebody said to me well without fear
there's no courage which is true I had a
director who had a wonderful phrase
whenever we had really tough things and
I wasn't sure he'd say well this is a
character building experience and of
course as you look back on I mean so
right I mean this is when you do build
character you have these gut wrenching
stomach-turning
sleepless night that's where you learn
the most and of course you doubt but
what you don't doubt is that you're
trying to do the right thing I think
that's what keeps you in there in the
right spot about that you're trying to
do the right thing for the right reasons
for the group not for you not for your
personal stake for the group as long as
you're trying that you're still you'll
doubt a lot is it going to happen what's
going to happen if it doesn't go right
but if you're trying to do the right
thing and doing it as well as you can
then I think you don't have the self
doubts maybe comment on balancing the
various constituencies as a leader I
think is that as employees shareholders
do you blog roll from one to the other
to what extent would you maybe put your
family second place versus employees
family situation well it's definitely a
balancing act and life is all about
balance and business is about balance
you've got you've got to make it a great
place to work for staff it's got to be a
great place to invest for owners it's
got to be a great place to do business
for customers you know if you if you're
not attending to all of those things and
often making some trade-offs but trying
to get it in balance if it's too far one
way or another it just doesn't work I
can remember when I first went to
Westpac the great thing they had a great
culture of the taking care of the
customer but it was so great that they'd
often take us standard pre-printed
contract and cross it out and make the
changes that the customer wanted so you
know we didn't even know actually what
we had in terms of our loan agreements
or portfolio commitments so you had to
then do a lot of time with stuff look
that's not necessarily good for the
customer it's certainly not going to be
good for us if we create losses so it's
just a constant communication about
balance I think so but but you have to
find it I mean that's the role of
finding a balance of those various
interests so that people feel good it's
the same thing here between faculty and
students and staff and alumni and the
university and recruiters they've all
got a feel you know this is a really
good school this is a good situation so
if if somebody's being left out or in
weak position you've got to work hard to
bring it back and I you know I guess to
say the same thing goes for you and your
family and your life and your work you
you have to try the best you can we're
all imperfect human beings we don't get
it right but as long as you're trying
and you're aware of the need for balance
I think that's the key from an
organizational perspective what would be
our two to three biggest pieces of
advice for professors alone are taking
on
Eugene I'd give the same advice to
anybody taking on a leadership role I
think don't take yourself too seriously
listen a lot and and then probably just
those four things you know have a view
you got to be the view you got to try to
figure out what's going on all the time
you have to try to be sure that you're
turning the view into reality you know
the vision thank you very much I really
really enjoyed your talk one of the
things I was wondering with the picture
of thinking maybe your grandson
[Music]
okay he's a good guy so that's Adam I'm
wondering you know when you were in
business school and applying what
mattered most to you and why and what
does that answer now and if it's changed
you know what's what's going on with
that you well it's good quite we didn't
have that question then
so I can't go back and look at the essay
but I can tell you how I felt you know I
left as an undergrad and a young family
and a new marriage and I was working in
a real estate business outside of
Seattle and I realized very quickly how
little I knew and how much I wanted I
wanted to know a lot more about
management and organizations I didn't
want to be in a spot where I felt
trapped and dependent on a small
business organization which I was I was
learning a lot about business and I did
learn a lot at the time but I really
really had this sense I wanting to
invest in myself to acquire a much
stronger body of knowledge about
management and organizations that's what
really mattered to me so that I could so
that I could do something I wanted to do
something you know I think if you have
as your aspiration in life to be
something you never can control that but
if your aspiration is to do something do
some kind of work that you think is good
work you can control that and if that
makes you famous great if it doesn't
great you know but you will have been
doing things that you really thought
mattered and you know what I always
wanted to be doing something that I
thought was important work and that's
what led me to the choices I made in
terms of the work I saw it it felt good
to me it was right for me it was work I
thought I could do well if I made the
investment in a commitment and a key
part of that was the investment I made
in coming here so that I really could
could do it well points your career that
kind of led to your gang to top and
maybe what you thought at the time
oh boy there there'd be lots of them but
I'm just trying to think of some
particularly poignant ones one of the
really big turning point usually a
turning point can be a real crisis or
failure I took over an area trust an
investment at Wells Fargo and I had a
real disagreement with the way it was
going and I just thought back to Carol's
question I was going to have to make the
tough call I decided to terminate
somebody so that we could have a you
know kind of fresh start about things
and six other people quit the entire
management team sent me an email and
said we're leaving and going to form a
new firm at a competitor and you know
that was pretty daunting that was
character building but having to deal
with that and pick myself up and find a
new leader and realizing well it's not
the end of the world and maybe I can
work my way through it and I think doing
it and as tough a situation as that was
and building something that turned out
to be much much better than what we had
so so there was a certain sense I did
the right thing I probably did it very
clumsily and in hindsight I could have
done it better you always learn from the
doing but it was a it was a big turning
point I think for me in dealing with
tough situations like that and the
people who were my supervisors saying
wow he got himself in and out of a very
tough situation and we're better off for
it so I think that was one very real
example I mean obviously you know
deciding to get on a plane and go to
Australia and take on a big bank that I
knew nothing about was was won and you
know I can go on my best in worst
moments is Dean of the GSB Oh golly
there's so many good moments what can I
say I I think it's interesting and some
of you here in my class know that one of
the worst moments was the way that we
handled a situation at Schwab where
there was a lot of carousing and
partying and stuff and I sent a memo to
the students about all this and it it
just could have been done a lot better
that was that was perhaps a worse moment
I've had some others but you know
there's so many good moments it just
hardly any worse moments the worst
moment is leaving perhaps yeah back here
and then up here what leadership
mistakes do you see young MBAs make
early in their careers after leaving the
GSB I probably the biggest common
mistake is is taking on a leadership job
without truly taking responsibility for
the group thinking more about yourself
it's only natural that's what I thought
about when I was 27 years old as well
and thinking that with pure smarts you
can just get the right answer you can
get strategy is everything and if you
can come up with the right ideas and the
right strategy everybody will say wow
what a brilliant strategy let's go and
under estimating and missing all the
difficulties of bringing people along
particularly people that are different
from you that aren't like Stanford MBAs
are not like analysts that you've been
working for I'd say so I think the
biggest mistake they probably make is
getting into a spot getting excited
laying the strategy out for people and
finding you're just not moving it just
this this this view is not happening and
and then actually compounding it perhaps
by getting upset or getting angry at
people what's the matter they're just
not smart enough to understand my
strategy I think that's one we would
hear over and over again so looking at
your background seems that you worked in
three very different types of
environments in the in the public sector
as a White House Fellow years in the
private
during then 10 years in academia I'm
curious how was the the view of the
vantage point different in those three
types of settings and how did you have
to evolve our adapt your leadership
style as you move from one to the other
well that's a very good question and
certainly you know being being Dean of a
Business School is very different than
being a CEO I often tell alumni look
it's not like being a CEO it's like
being a managing partner if you think of
a law firm or consulting firm or
professional firm the partners
periodically elect someone to be the
managing partner most partners don't
aspire to be managing partner and for
them they'd much rather be a partner but
they realize somebody has to do it you
know somebody has to count the beans and
open the doors and keep the place
running and so there's lots of partners
meetings and you have to be good at
consulting with and engaging and
involving partners I so that that's just
it's just very different it's also
different in the sense of your one
school among seven within a larger
University and I think one of the
reasons that I've been so interested and
passionate about engaging the GSB with
the university is that I used to be a
CEO that's not often that a Dean is in
that spot and so I knew as CEO where I
had multiple division heads I didn't
like having the division heads all off
completely on their own and not feeling
part of the group and part of the team
so I knew how John Hennessy would feel
that you know it would be good if we
could get the seven schools really
working together wherever they can it
just makes for a great organization now
that's a perspective that I had you know
my time in government so and the other
big difference of course you know in
business you kind of line up where we're
saying what's in it for the customer the
employee the investor and you can
measure those things and you have a
sense for what a great business is when
you try to have it be a great school you
want it great for students and staff and
alumni and recruiters the metrics aren't
there as well so you just have a much
tougher job I think of creating a common
sense of vision about what's a great
school all about and what's your role in
it
and my time in government was very young
and at an early stage in my career I
mean to me I learned there it's more
what I learned than what I saw that the
power of doing meaningful work is very
strong you know when you're doing the
work that you think is the most
important work in the world for the
country it's very motivating and very
powerful and I felt that very strongly
there and it makes you realize that if
you can get a sense of mission and
meaning for people in their work it's
incredibly strong and it's much stronger
than money
how we doing for time guys
what last question okay so you mentioned
moral courage and I was wondering what
you think the GSB can do as an
institution or what individuals within
the GSB can do to make it more likely
that students exhibit moral courage in
the future then you know this about the
same as it was when they came in well
it's a very very good question I think
about that a lot and I think it's
something as a faculty we should
challenge ourselves with could we do a
better job I always think of the three
A's you know when you've got a problem
don't know why I do three C's three days
where you know there's awareness there's
analysis and there's action right if
you're not even aware that it's a
problem you're not going to do anything
and this is one of the issues around
ethical challenges you know you've got
to be aware that wow this smells and
feels to me like an ethical problem so
there's awareness and I think we can do
somewhat of a better job in how do we
teach people about awareness and how do
our you have your antenna up about
things that could be a slippery slope
analysis I think we do really well once
you're aware and one of the pre on what
are the issues and how could you resolve
and how could you balance but then it's
action you know how do you teach action
which is all about having the courage to
act the only way I know is to be in a
spot where you're responsible so to me
the only way to teach that or give
people a leg up is to hold them
responsible for certain actions where
they would they actually have to act
more and I always think we could
probably give more to students to do
here not so much more academic work more
responsibility for how the school
operates and runs and the culture and
the climate and so you have to act and
you have to speak up and you have to
call on another classmate or or
colleague about something that's not
right I think that's one way you learn
it by having to be and maybe we have to
formalize that you're on this committee
and you're on that I don't know but you
only learn it by doing it's one of those
I do and I understand things well let me
again say to the committee thanks for
the invitation thank you for coming I am
very pleased that my mother who just
came back with me from her 75th college
reunion there were only two people there
from her class from her class and she
was the only ambulatory one so she got
to lead the parade which is pretty
spectacular and it's really nice
you